hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play condemned
ok we're in this weird building complex
and um I'm actually I'm actually not
sure where I'm supposed to go because
this looks exactly like where I was but
obviously because the checkpoint just
got saved I'm supposed to go this way or
not how about no you're gonna you're
gonna do that to me fish I bushu
bearishness ah how's it gonna be like
that I don't know I just went down here
I don't think I'd clear this out so if
that's the case then oh no here we go
no that was a lie that was a dirty dirty
lie I'm a dirty liar how about the
sledgehammer is anything I can do with
this huh uh huh
oh wait maybe oh holy crap I better get
up there
flip wait a minute no I'm gonna hold
onto this I can take you with my super
girl dude ever how about the balls in
the balls again I mean in the balls oh I
can't my aim is off da hell oh hell oh
no god damn it
please die thank you Oh miss me good
lordy Lou I'm just I'm not expecting
things and you startled me
why'd you startled me oh my really
hi what are you doing mister lady are
you mister or lady how about you shut up
they're like slime
totally normally there we go all right
nope don't even bother right what how
about a sledgehammer up y'all but how
did that feel good well then you're a
weirdo huh oh you're not the same whoa
come on you really got to bring a gun to
this fight crap oh my dodge barge
give me the gun give me the gun give me
the gun give me the gun bump I'll cry
you gotta be kidding me oh thank you
good morning some machine gun maximum
bullets I love it
yes I love that machine gun huh yes I
love it oh hello
kind of forgot that I was actually in a
school for a little bit there up grabbed
up what you that didn't know you really
how about this huh head butt like a
mouse ah such a BYOs anyway let's go
anybody oh yeah that's look good
yeah I'm just running circles in this
frickin place wherever this it Wow hi hi
hi hi
Oh fire axe required fudge why don't you
give me a part oh hi
saw that who do you think I guess our
search this does not look good I've seen
a few good things in my life not many
but some and I know that this is not
good the blood is kind of a telltale
sign oh it's cold in here
ah yeah but now you still like hell are
you what why that doesn't make any sense
at all oh good lordy
what's wrong with you crazy people
you're like that psychos from ah how
about a shove it oh you're gonna time ah
yeah Oh what that uh ah oh oh you took
meat cleaver now this is actually a
personal legitimate knife they better
know I guess Oh fire axe is also an axe
hi oh I forgot that the fire axe is
actually quite powerful and deadly I
guess that makes sense considering it is
an axe so I didn't mean to yell at you
it's not you I used up all my ammo on
fatso back there oh happy like that Oh
what the balls you're not supposed to
have a 10 billion yard we all right that
was my fault I know I should have I
should have backed up that was mine oh
sorry
getting through that door is a little
orgasmic
hello studious ball I'm gonna happen is
something going to happen here okay by
the way I just want to comment that
these new studio headphones plug into my
my blue Yeti USB and I sling I can
actually hear my voice in my headphones
in real time it actually helps it really
does it's kind of interesting too okay
what was the point of coming down here
am I supposed to break through the
floorboards here like a mouse
no okay maybe I'm supposed to make some
fall I'm actually kind of confused I oh
why would this be here if it wasn't to
fall down I mean obviously I'm books go
here floor in some way I think that is
what supposed to happen yes now yes now
away here we go duh duh oh boy I'm such
a doofus
why they're an arm on that did some guys
slam-dunk a little too Hardy right this
is trick I'm going I'm going ladies blue
flub no block milk good
transfer complete good it's your prints
from his personnel file actually I had
right okay
that's um that's good
hello and fall yeah haha yeah
destruction and chaos these are just
some of my favorite things
Oh piece of metal ah you're a piece of
metal I'm a piece of metal when things
get real hot
click we kind of fuse together you see
our legs they wrap around they are let
oh never mind
obscure whose line reference that
probably no one is ever gonna get raise
your hand if you got that reference if
you knew what I know probably knew what
I was talking about if you did I'll be
your best friend forever
no probably no one
how do I crouch again can't I even
crouch I don't think I can crouch how I
get through there hi I want to get thro
there that's the only way through
apparently right isn't it wait a minute
wait a minute
I'm not just [ __ ] around and I don't
remember how to crouch I really don't
remember how to crouch do i crouching is
a night oh wait no oh god could have
gone through here we're not because I
can't do anything about this oh all
right I'm an idiot I'm an idiot I'm
getting more unobservant or less
observant more unobservant as i play
games I I seriously have a degradation
in my attention here that of the
character I'm playing is being dumb ergo
I think I'm freaking dumb too
are you big and dumb too wait a minute
what does that go confused yeah no I get
bored I got a dead bird only one I've
been failing on the dead unlock
achievement hey test pattern hey that
was so hard I'm glad I achieved that ah
all right let's see you us up here hello
everybody Adele anybody know I'm outside
why am i outside what's that I trying to
find something inside wasn't that the
whole deal and wasn't that the whole
deal
also shall be finding the dead boo hello
is this on mr. Tibbets you're missing a
not away what hi what a manatee key come
on
what what I just wanted to make you
Oh
okey-dokey I'm being Myrtle eyes as we
speak just not here
or am I being murdered here I actually
don't know I'm kind of confused now they
would only five bullets I'll take a bone
huh boo don't align all that World War
one rifle is here Oh be more drab red
balls live over damn Wow hey thank you
for fighting each other in dammit and
what the hell who did that
you all right never mind I'm staying out
of that fight okay why am i jumping down
here this seems like a no-go what that
it was glass that didn't look like glass
I must save I'm saved
Oh Oh No
Wow
yeah that guy don't look too good
saving checkpoint
oh I guess I'm renewing ready following
a trail of blood or something nope okay
hey get that out there again ire go fine
I need to collect all this blood what am
i some kind of weirdo ah walls okay
really did I need to know that my super
instincts told me that a long time ago
okay who's in there hey oh hey the hell
is going on here
oh hi I saw you do you want to come over
here but probably all sorts of dead
birds that I'm missing but I I like I
care I live on the edge man I don't need
to scoop a dead birds even though I
really like the dead birds the dead
birds in my friends I like them a lot oh
oh god I'm so strong oh no thank you
and you're dead things all you're good
for these days is dying
cuz I'm so great seriously I'm like the
best there ever was in case you didn't
know my name is markiplier and I am the
greatest ever maybe huh
grace detective ever hello really that's
how you're gonna play it really oh I
gotta find a shovel now unless I can
just sprint through them oh I'm so smart
I bet I can I mean it's just steam right
can't kill me that'd be totally a lot of
no help they will put its solid steam
it's very strong steam it's thick mm-hmm
so I need to find a shovel well fan
fantastic I love fine and shovels argh
blood nope no shovel there any shovel
back here nope no shovel back here well
this is fantastic I love this I love not
having a shovel nearby and having to
backtrack and find one unless it was one
right in the area which I don't know
I'll figure it out after the break
cuz I am all out of time thank you all
so much for watching it I thought I had
something to say but I I think I forgot
about it so hope y'all can forgive me
for that anyway thanks again for
watching click the annotations for more
videos that I've done and as always I'll
see you in the next part bye bye